Welcome to the unit on Modules and Classes. As we build larger and more complex
programs we quickly end up with programs that are far too big for one person to
keep in their head at any one time. One solution to this would be to have your
head explode, this only works once. Instead what we need are Techniques to
Manage Complexity. And that's going to be the focus of this unit as well as some
of the things that we cover in later lessons. This is one of the main things
that distinguishes experienced programmers from beginners, is this ability to
Manage Complexity, to deal with larger and larger programs. And the biggest idea
for that is actually modularity. Unlike exploding heads, breaking up programs
into pieces is actually a good thing. In this unit we'll look at two mechanisms
that Python provides top help programmers break things up into pieces in a way
that doesn't make your head explode. The first is Modules, and the second is
Classes. By using these ideas well you'll be able to construct large and complex
programs without your head blowing up into pieces.